foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
of the moment and not only in Argentina
his victory in the Paso has catapulted
him to an international level and now
there are many who want to take
advantage of his victory in one way or
another Lopez obrador evoked the ghosts
of Hitler and Nazism when explaining
melay's Triumph
bolsonarismo celebrated melaye's victory
in the Paso it could be the real change
that Argentina needs for the first time
a Libertarian candidate has a serious
possibility of winning the presidency of
a country like Argentina while melee was
an unknown and the phenomenon of his
support may have been a simple
manifestation of weariness after the
Paso it has become a totally real option
the Wall Street Bank that anticipates
Amy lay win in the presidential election
according to Wells Fargo the libertarian
candidate has a 65 chance of being
elected president this year
Javier melaye anticipated that he he was
contacted by the IMF and that they will
meet in the next few days now how did
such a Libertarian wave take shape in
the land of the Gaucho where does it
come from and what exactly are melee's
positions what is his plan for Argentina
well visual politic community in this
video we're going to answer all of these
questions so let's find out what's
behind the melee tsunami let's get
cracking
[Music]
despite its ups and downs and economic
matters Argentine politics has to a
certain extent more or less a constant
threat in the first part of the 20th
century with the consolidation of
democracy the radical Civic Union
emerged the first major Mass party which
in fact won the first three open
elections those of 1916 1922 and 1928.
then of course the Armed Forces got
fully involved in life with a 1930 coup
d'etat from that moment on Argentine
democracy was let's just say
intermittent at best coup d'etat has
followed one after another and for years
democracy was limited to certain periods
of time in one of those spaces Juan
Domingo Peron emerged who founded the
peronist movement and he laid what would
become the foundations of Argentine
democracy from then on on the one hand
anti-paronism usually linked to the
radical Civic Union and their allies and
on the other hand purunism supported by
the justdialist party so there we have
it this is the tandem that has
completely dominated Argentine politics
since the return of democracy in 1983 in
the last decade this Jew has been
represented under its various names by
the opposition Coalition together for
Change and for the ruling peronist
Coalition Union for the Homeland and so
it was until a third Force saw a gap and
suddenly entered the politics of a
country with a devastated economy of
course we are talking about La libertad
avanza Liberty advances Javier melaye's
political party
in the Paso of 2023 the Libertarians not
only achieved an unprecedented National
Victory but also obtained an enormous
amount of votes in the interior of the
country in provinces and municipalities
that were authentic peronist strongholds
in fact in both the federal capital and
in the province of Buenos Aires together
for Change and Union for the Homeland
were able to retain their votes so that
means Javier melaye achieved his
National Triumph thanks to victories in
places where no detractor of peruism has
achieved six feet at least not in the
last five decades but what exactly was
the window of opportunity that melaye
had advantage of how on Earth did he
manage to generate such an electoral
Maelstrom a guy who came to politics in
2019. these are the first two questions
we have to answer before seeing exactly
what melee wants to do with Argentina so
let's get into it
[Music]
the seed disenchantment with macri
coralito and the collapse of 2001 gave
way to a country where the exchange rate
the latest inflation figures and
salaries are the focus of excessive
social attention perhaps that is why
although it might seem strange to you in
the land of Eternal crises economics is
the number one degree in Argentine
universities every year almost 15
000 economists graduate in Argentina the
constant crisis has made economic issues
in Argentina a huge and growing
political and social preoccupation the
economy is the real rock star of the
political debate in Argentina at
Christmas dinner inflation is a popular
topic and guess what thanks to all this
media Maelstrom One Fine Day an
economist who would gradually stand out
from the crowd found space in the media
we are talking of course about Javier
Miele this is from 25th of August 2015.
check it out alternatives
needle gradually and thanks to the 2015
campaign the new libertarian icon began
to have more and more presence in the
media at that time melee's interventions
had a more technical profile his
criticism of the price interventions
carried out by the government of
Christina Fernandez de Kirchner stood
out above all
[Music]
be nice at me the fact is that in those
elections puronism lost Mercurio macri
became the new president of Argentina on
the 10th of December of that same year
hopes for a great change were more than
palpable expectations were Sky High
probably too high
Dimas
medicine
mccree's government had to deal with a
lot of problems in 2016. the debate the
great debate was whether the new
government should apply a shock policy
or bet on gradual programs that would
introduce changes little by little in
the end the second possibility won the
attempt to seek a certain stability
during the reforms and a higher level of
consensus and social peace made
government moves so gradual that in the
end most of the changes were barely
perceptible due to this very soon
macrismo failed to meet all the
expectations that were placed on this
new era in the end neither public
spending was reduced by that much nor
was the deficit being eliminated nor was
a great liberalization of the economy
being approved everything remained more
or less the same fiscal deficit the
target is met but still delays growth
the government maintains its strategy of
gradual reduction of the budget in the
red which it finances with debt but also
determines the recovery of activity in
2017. it was then when melee positioned
himself as a model for those who agreed
with the first path go fast and go deep
it was here when the most heated version
of this candidate was born the formula
that would lead him to become the third
pathway for Argentine politics melee
warned that gradual adjustment plans end
in crisis
[Music]
in the end mccree's government was a
disaster with inflation skyrocketing and
a very bad economic situation he had to
end up asking once again for a bailout
from the IMF not surprisingly in the
following elections peruism returned and
it did it what's more through the front
door they did not even need to reach the
second round of voting
[Music]
foreign
elections there was a pro market
alternative that of Jose Luis esper he
barely obtained 1.47 of the votes but
that meant the clearing of a path that
would remain open in the following
legislative elections esper and Millay
led a joint alternative that received
almost 1.3 million votes
this was the great political debut of
melaye who ended up being Deputy for the
federal capital with 17 of the votes in
total at the national level the
libertarian platform won four deputies
that was the beginning from then on
melee's prominence took off
exponentially with peruism back in
government his tough message began to
cut on more and more melee suddenly
became one of the main opposition
figures and of course with such a
disastrous government and on top of that
with the pandemic arriving right in the
middle of everything peruism began to
unravel at times everything seemed to be
a real design faster
Argentina's vaccine Scandal Health
Minister resigns after Revelations of
irregular vaccination of officials and
other VIPs
Argentina Remains the worst country to
spend the pandemic in according to
Bloomberg ranking
Argentine education at its worst at the
end of last year laxo researcher
Augustine Klaus warned about a
projection showing that almost 1.5
million children dropped out of school
after the quarantine and then came the
inflation rates of 40 50 80 and even 100
also the total lack of reserves and all
of the crises the country was going
through which is something we have
already talked about here on
visualpolitik in the video on the end of
peruism that was released just a few
days ago
Argentina was beginning to want to
change and there was now more options
there was no reason to be limited to
gradualism many people were fed up and
wanted a firm clear decisive leader that
was the best breeding ground for
melaye's libertarian narrative to take
root
[Applause]
and that is exactly what happened Miley
began to work on his presidential
candidacy in 2022 and barely a year
later the result was delivered
[Music]
Argentina
[Applause]
now of course the big challenge is the
elections and here unlike together for
change the libertad avanza project is
much more cohesive everything resolves
around melee a candidate who can now
claim the useful vote against peruism
Mile's numbers say that he is in a
position to win especially if he
achieves a second round against peronis
candidate Sergio Masa which does not
seem a far-fetched scenario
[Music]
it's taken for granted unless there is
an economic debacle in the next month
that significant number of the votes
that we're going to go to Loretta and
the primaries may not go to bullrich but
to the peruist candidate Loretta was
bulrich's opponent to run for president
representing together for change the key
is that buldrich has more conservative
and pro-market possessions than Loretta
who is more inclined to establish
understandings with the peronists if
that is so buildrich would need to
mobilize a large part of the vote that
has not participated in the primaries
for herself it does not seem a
particularly easy Challenge and that's
what explains why Wells Fargo gives me
lay a 65 chance of being president on
the other hand if Bill Rich manages to
overcome Massa and to go to the second
round against melee then the fight would
probably be much closer in any case
everything indicates that peruism will
have a very hard time indeed all this of
course is if Malay does not have any
more setbacks like this one regarding
the sale of organs
[Music]
is going to try to relaunch its options
on the fear vote isn't this giving them
a Lifeline be that as it may if there is
one thing that is clear it is that today
melee is very likely to end up being the
president of Argentina the question
logically is what are his plans what is
the basis of the Revolution he wants to
carry out to turn Argentina back into a
rich and prosperous country
well first of all he promises to carry
out a major reform of the state he has
committed himself to reducing public
spending by 15 immediately to reduce the
number of Ministries from 18 to 8 to
progressively put an end to social
payments to replace public works with
concessions and to privatize many of the
companies still owned by the state we
are talking for example about ariolinas
Argentinas or the oil company ypf that
is what Libertarians have called the
chainsaw planned
Italian
s
but that is not all at the same time
milei has also pledged to push for
another major reform of education and
also of the Health Care System
libertarian candidate's idea would be to
guarantee universal access to these
services but changing the current system
to one of insurance in the case of
healthcare or vouchers in the case of
Education in this way argentines would
receive an entitlement that they could
then exchange for the health insurance
and educational centers of their choice
such a model would generate competition
and private players would be able to
compete on equal terms over time it is
understood that receiving the education
check or having the state cover the cost
of health insurance would be limited
according to income and so little by
little a system could be created to
which everyone would have access but
which would have much more competition
much less cost for the public coffers
and a more efficient way of functioning
it is believed
foreign
has advocated free trade a million times
and that is exactly what he wants for
the country for it to reduce all
possible barriers and unilaterally open
up to global trade and then there is of
course what we can consider as his star
proposal according to melaye the
definitive plan to put an end to the
Eternal problem of inflation in
Argentina we are talking naturally about
the dollarization of the country
um
along with this melee also promises to
end many of the regulations that affect
Argentine economic life we are talking
about Labor regulations price
regulations Professional Regulations and
also tax reductions in other words what
Javier melee basically wants is to
transform the country's productive
system from top to bottom so the
question we have to ask is logically is
all of this really even possible let's
find out
[Music]
rule with a chainsaw
foreign
politic viewers it stands to reason that
in order to carry out all the reforms
promised by Miley he would not only need
to win the presidential elections he
would also have to get the support of
the parliament the problem is that in
Argentina the renewal of the chambers is
partial in each election half of the
Chamber of deputies and one-third of the
Senate are renewed this means that even
if miele's parties obtains the same
level of support in the first round as
it did in the Paso this libertarian
grouping could not get much more than
about 40 deputies and eight Senators
this of course would leave it far from
being able to control a congress
composed of a total of 72 senators and
25 deputies yes the sum of Liberty
advances and together for change would
have a very clear majority but Miley
would have to negotiate and he would
have to do so not only with a single
party but with a legislative force that
in Argentina is usually quite diverse
even if the candidates run on the same
platforms as together for change there
are usually many different currents the
question is would melee be able to
negotiate and reach agreements with the
opposition
[Music]
well the truth is that he himself has
doubts that such a process could come to
fruition especially with regard to Major
reforms mind you he does claim to have a
plan
the libertarian candidate has said that
he would resort to popular referenda and
not only in the case of dollarization
but also from many other policies
including high voltage issues such as
for example the legalization of abortion
this is something that raises certain
concerns not only within the political
environment but there are also serious
doubts about the legal framework for
this action and here the law a law that
could not be changed without the
agreement of the opposition seems quite
clear the law calling for a binding
popular consultation must be dealt with
in a special session and be approved by
the vote of the absolute majority of
members present in each of the houses
that is President melaye could only call
for non-binding referenda without prior
legislative approval yes he could submit
a referendum win it and then put
pressure on Congress but let's be clear
about one thing this would generate lots
and lots of tension and not only that it
wouldn't be a particularly quick process
either
thank you
as it stands melee is creating a lot of
expectations and a possible political
blockage could either make him lose his
political momentum or in order to try
and keep the ship afloat throw himself
at the neck of the legisler who knows
where that would end up it would
certainly not be a good thing because
there are two big risks that exist
because the problem arises and we have
seen it in other Latin American
countries when a president creates many
expectations and that does not have the
support to carry out those promised
changes but let's make it clear that
this does not mean that melee could not
get his way for example by reaching a
major agreement with together for change
or intelligently using non-binding
referendums to increase his legislative
influence in two years what we mean is
that the risk that he might not succeed
and that this might have consequences is
definitely at The Forum especially when
we are talking about a candidate who is
not in favor of seeking many agreements
no
foreign
[Applause]
of course there may be something or
someone that we are losing sight of a
profile that has been acting behind the
scenes lately and that in the not too
distant future may play a key role in
this entire story we are of course
talking about Maurizio mackley himself
it is obvious that I think we are going
to go to a second round with this new
more pro market more rupturist and angry
expression of the frustration that
Argentina has been dragging for years
the candidate of together for change who
is in that position will have to
demonstrate that beyond the rupturist
and change intentions that Malay has we
have the same but with experience and
that should tilt the balance in our
favor the former Argentine president not
only had a premonition months ago about
the libertarian wave but has long been
particularly close to Javier melee
himself to such an extent that last year
the libertarian leader raised this
possibility
Ministry
of course elections and electoral combat
typically create many fractures in any
case macri could be the key to seeking a
joint reform agenda but for now if one
thing is clear does that mean lay
proposes to reform Argentina from top to
bottom and that now for the first time
he has a good chance of becoming the new
president of Argentina risks and
opportunities are on the table and apart
from that you know the story we don't
really have a crystal ball so for this
point the questions are over to you what
is your opinion of Javier me Lee what do
you think of his political plan do you
think he will really end up being the
new president of Argentina leave us your
thoughts in the comments below and let's
start a respectful debate and now if you
found this video interesting don't
forget to like it and subscribe to all
of us here at visualpolitik if you
haven't already done so thanks very much
for watching I hope you enjoyed the
video and I'll see you next time
[Music]